Sally were here at the launch for the
London Film Fest well you've got your
film here this year tell me all about er
my film my brother the devil is in
competition I'm really excited because
it's the UK premiere and also it's a
London movie it was the whole film is
set in Hackney a lot of the cast come
from kind of London
a young cast so for it to come home to
London Film Festival and for the
premiere to be here is just wonderful
news is exciting for the whole cast and
crew who worked really hard tell me a
bit about the inspiration behind the
film there isn't one place that it comes
from I've lived in Hackney for over ten
years so that's why it's out there I
guess the the main characters are
British Egyptian brothers teenage boys
and half Egyptian so I certainly like
drew upon my own kind of background in
terms of like that culturally specific
viewpoint but really it's a
multicultural film there are kids you
know from Somalia and Nigeria you know
all different colors and creeds the way
London really is and tell me about the
young guys who were the starter as well
because they are phenomenal aren't they
Fadi al Sayyed who plays mode the little
brother is actually his first film and
it's um he lives not far from where we
shot the film so and he is Egyptian as
well he's incredible and he was so
dedicated to the Fermi actually it was
his 18th birthday when we were shooting
and he didn't celebrate he put his whole
birthday on hold until we'd finished
filming that's how seriously he took it
which was which was amazing and James
Floyd who's a kind of rising star I
guess he plays Rashid the big like most
big brother and he went berry method
because his background is and alls isn't
very like street so he kind of got to
know a lot of the guys that I knew he
spent five months kind of going
undercover and it's really going about
the whole preparation in a very method
way and learning everything like that
hang out
and a lot how did that help you as a
director because it's in first film as a
director you're right written it as well
it's quite a big task to take on isn't
it yeah well I guess so I mean for me
this films when you make a film is
there's such a part of you after five
years of kind of half a decade really of
dedicating your life to like one project
you better kind of approach it with a
mentality that if you only have one
phone to make before you die what's that
feeling going to mean so that's
certainly kind of the mentality that I
approach to it now it's a film that is
quite different to other films on kind
of similar subjects how did you make the
kind of decisions behind the characters
you have in there in the journey they go
on it was it was a very organic process
I mean I the film took five years to
make and for many years about five years
I was developing the script I got to
know a lot of boys who were involved in
gangs in different areas of London and
did a lot of research with them Eamonn
Holmes uchi who plays repo in the film
he was my script consultants and one of
my key people and I was kind of doing
all my research and I just started
hanging around lots of them sixteen
seventeen year old boys for many years
and you know when I was spending all
this time with them I saw how much
pressure there was that they were
putting on themselves to be men
and there was all this kind of machismo
going on so I kind of wanted to explore
that in terms of the story and the movie
and tell me about getting the language
right so you say it's very specific
isn't it to an age group as well yeah
well as you can probably hear and see I
don't speak you know urban London but I
certainly learnt the language and it was
like learning a foreign language
and by you know later kind of drafts I'd
share what I've written with the script
consultant and he's like God you don't
need me anymore
you're getting it all right and what are
you up to next Sally I'm writing so I'm
writing a few scripts at the moment for
other films one's a London Film that's
the one that I'm mainly most like
passionate about the moments we kind of
look forward to in terms of maybe the
genre or the feel of style of them it's
different to my brother the devil I
think I need a change so almost like a
response from over the devas could be
different worlds but it is a worlds in
that same way that my brother the devil
is a very specific an authentic world so
is this next one but a different world
you